fue hogar de más de 400.000 personas
mariupol era una joya brillante de la
industria ucraniana el mayor centro de
comercio en el mar de azov su puerto y
su industria metalúrgica eran clave para
la economía del país hasta que el 24 de
febrero comenzó la invasión rusa a
principios de marzo los bombardeos se
habían convertido los complejos de
apartamentos de mariupol en torres de
escombros para el 7 de marzo las tropas
rusas habían rodeado la ciudad cortaron
el acceso a alimentos la electricidad
los suministros médicos y la mayoría de
rutas de escape para los civiles
entonces el 9 de marzo los proyectiles
alcanzaron un hospital de maternidad de
la ciudad las imágenes de madres
embarazadas heridas conmocionaron al
mundo pero a mariupol todavía le
esperaban más horrores el 16 de marzo
atacaron el teatro del tejado rojo
símbolo de la creciente prosperidad y
cultura de la ciudad más de 1000 civiles
se habían refugiado en su interior tras
no poder escapar de la localidad
asediada se cree que hasta 600 personas
entre muchos niños perecieron según
testimonios de supervivientes dados a la
agencia de noticias ap el bloqueo de
mariupol pasará a la historia de la
responsabilidad por los crímenes de
guerra es un terror que se recordara
durante siglos
cuando las fuerzas rusas tomaron la
mayor parte de la ciudad el único
reducto que quedaba era su principal
fábrica de acero la planta de aceptar
sus kilométricos pasillos subterráneos y
búnkeres proporcionaron una protección
ideal durante más de dos meses y medio
los soldados ucranianos consiguieron
junto a los civiles resistir allí con su
salida es el último reducto de mario
porque cambia de manos a sólo unos 600
kilómetros de la frontera rusa mariupol
ha sufrido un fuerte asedio debido a su
ubicación estratégica la ciudad es una
vía de paso o enlace terrestre entre los
territorios respaldados por rusia en el
este y crimea en el sur y tomar el
control de su industria metalúrgica y
del mar de azov proporcionaría a moscú
una victoria simbólica y económica a
costa de decenas de miles de vidas